calvin klein was all about volume the
proportions were really intense that i
liked it a lot of their looks in the
beginning had this croc detail on the
shoulder that was very cool
you know it's something that's a little
fashion-forward and it's kind of a
statement but if you're daring go for it
there was a double-breasted overcoat
named camel that i thought was quite
nice
there also was this really beautiful
beige croc backpack
each of those new Kennelly always does
this really cool technical fabrics they
had these amazing laser-cut sweaters
that almost look like tiny cubes a lot
of the coats had hoods on them that I
thought were very interesting the
trousers were a wider cut especially
with the fit of the jackets a lot of
them fell at the waist was a very nice
proportion for the pieces I liked the
fact that he would mix technical pieces
with more of a traditional cut item so
for example there was a bunch of suits
that were you know cut in the Calvin
Klein way however they were this really
great printed fabric so it looks super
modern
follow me on twitter at details Matt and
don't forget to check out details comm
we have a lot of videos happening later
this week